Would you please hold me?
In "Love Story," the 1970 tearjerker,...
...the couple is shattered, as Jennifer, Oliver's wife, loses her battle to cancer.
Oliver along with millions of viewers the world over were left to mourn.
James Cameron's "Titanic" is more recent but still uses the classic formula:...
...love unites, life separates, but love endures.
We're gonna make it, Rose. Trust me.
I trust you.
The love story of Jack Dawson and his upper crust lover Rose...
...is as short as the ocean liner's ill-fated trip.
Rose survives, and with her, so does her love for Jack.
The film garnered 11 Academy Awards and broke the box office record of all time,...
...at least until "Avatar".
It also made Leonardo DiCaprio and Kate Winslet superstars.
But "Titanic" aside, young people today seem to prefer more realistic on-screen romances,...
...like this young lady.
I think the younger generation is a little bit more cynical.
And I think there's a little less loyalty in general.
Regardless of age, few can resist true love...
...when they find it, even if it's just for a couple of hours inside a dark theater.